[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
NANCY KANWISHER: All right.
So I'm going to finish
up some of the things
that I talked about with
experimental design last time.
And then we're going
to get on and talk
about category-selective
regions in the cortex,
which, of course, we've been
talking about in various ways
all along.
But I'll raise some
general controversies
about that, some alternative
views from the kind of one
that I've been foisting
on you, and what
I consider to be some
of the strongest,
most important evidence
against the view
that I've been
putting forth here.
And then we'll talk about
decoding signals from brains.
That's the agenda.
Here we go.
So last time, I had
you guys work in groups
to think about experimental
design because, really,
most decisions about
experimental design,
once you know the bare basics
of the measurement methods,
they're just applying
common sense,
thinking about what it's
like for the subject.
How are you going to
get the data you need?
So in terms of what
exact conditions to run
in any experiment, I
talked about the idea
of a minimal pair, this
kind of platonic ideal
of the perfect contrast,
which never exists in reality
but that you aspire toward.
So ideally, you
want two conditions
that are identical, except
for the one little thing
that you're interested in.
And you don't want to have
other things that co-vary
with that thing
you're manipulating,
other than the thing
you're interested in.
And that's the crux of the
matter in experimental design.
You guys talked about
what kind of tasks
to have subjects
do in the scanner.
There's a trade-off between
kind of doing the most natural
thing, which is they're just
lying there and stimuli come--
visual, auditory, whatever--
versus the fact that
subjects might fall asleep
if they have nothing to do.
And if they fall
asleep, you won't know.
And that's not good.
So it's sometimes better to
have a task to keep them awake
and to tell you
that they're awake.
Key important point-- don't
have one task for one stimulus
condition and a different
task for a different stimulus
condition.
If you did, that would be a--
AUDIENCE: Confounder.
NANCY KANWISHER: Sorry?
NANCY KANWISHER: Confound.
Exactly.
That would be a confound.
Don't do that.
We talked about
baseline conditions.
So for example, in
a vision experiment,
staring at a dot or a
cross is kind of as far
as you can go in turning
off your visual system.
Why would you want
to bother with that?
Well, it's sometimes useful
to have that kind of baseline
because we sometimes
want to look
not just at a difference between
two conditions-- remember,
one condition alone in MRI
tells you not a damn thing.
All we can see is differences.
But even just two conditions
showing you a difference,
that's something.
But it can be ambiguous.
So for example, if you had a
situation like this where there
was a response in some brain
region to the red condition
here and the green
condition there-- they're
just two numbers.
That's all you have--
that is different.
That's kind of meh.
There's a difference,
but it's meh.
But if you have a good
baseline and you really
know that zero is zero or as
close to zero as you can get--
and now imagine
if zero was here.
That would be like, wow,
that's a really strong effect
and especially in neuroscience,
where we care a lot,
as you may have noticed,
about selectivity,
about how much more we
get a response in one
condition than another.
And selectivities
are usually more
interesting as a ratio
than as a difference,
as I'm illustrating here.
And so you can't get
a ratio unless you
have a third condition,
usually a baseline.
All right.
A few other things--
we talked about how you
allocate subjects to conditions.
You could have all
your subjects do--
one half of the subjects
do the face condition
for an hour in the scanner.
Another half of your subjects
do the object condition
for an hour in the scanner.
That's no good.
We don't want to do that.
We want a
within-subjects design.
We want all the conditions
within a subject
whenever we can do that.
Why?
Well, my best analogy
to this is suppose we
decided to grade your
assignments as follows.
A third of the class is going
to be graded only by Heather.
This third of the class is
going to be graded only by Dana.
Across the whole semester,
you guys are Heather people.
You guys are Dana people.
You guys are Anya people.
Is that fair?
No, that's dumb.
What if Heather's a hard-ass?
And she is kind of a hard-ass,
not that you guys aren't.
They're all a pretty
tough crew there.
I stand here just waiting
for the gong to go, wrong.
And you guys should do that.
I'm sure I've already said
wrong things and you knew it.
So next time, sound the
gong and correct me.
Anyway, that wouldn't be
fair in grading exams.
And neither is it good
in experimental design.
So for all the same reasons
that you guys can hopefully
get an intuition here, you
want to have all the conditions
within a person, because
maybe one person's brain just
activates more than
another person's brain.
Maybe this person
had more coffee.
Coffee increases
your bold response.
We give away free
chocolate espresso beans
before scans in my lab to
increase the MRI response.
All of that-- do designs within
subjects whenever possible.
How do you allocate conditions
to runs, these kind of subsets
of a whole hour-long
experiment where
you scan people for maybe
five minutes at a time
and give them a break
and another five minutes?
Well, the same logic applies.
Imagine you're in a
scanner for an hour.
You're getting sleepy.
You're getting bored.
You're thinking
about other things.
You're kind of not on the ball.
Those things change over
slow periods of time.
And so you want to get all
those conditions together
within a run, just as you want
to get conditions together
within a subject
whenever possible.
And so then we didn't
really get into this.
And I think you
did in your groups.
But how do we stick all
these conditions together
within a run?
Do we clump them
together in a batch?
Or do we interleave them?
And I think most
of you guys realize
that there's this deep
set of trade-offs there.
And so here's what's sometimes
called the block design, where
you clump a condition--
a whole bunch of trials
with one condition, then a
whole bunch of trials of another
with, in this case, some
kind of baseline in between,
versus a mixed interleaved
condition, which
is called event-related
for uninteresting
historical reasons.
And if it's event-related,
you can have it slow or fast.
So why wouldn't you--
what are the reasons to
do this rather than that?
Many of you guys came
up with this last time.
So nothing--
AUDIENCE: Biases.
NANCY KANWISHER: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Minimize the biases.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
What kind of biases?
AUDIENCE: In a
blocked experiment,
they might be biased by
what they're looking for.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
all kinds of biases.
Consider this trial here
in a yellow condition.
Well, you just did a
bunch of yellow trials.
So maybe your yellow system
is adapted out or something
or biased somehow.
But you also know that the
next one's going to be yellow.
And so there's all that
previous stuff and anticipatory
stuff, all on top
of the actual effect
of a single yellow trial.
Yeah.
Was that what you were
going to say, as well?
AUDIENCE: I was going to say
that you also have effects
from previous trials.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
all of those things,
the effects of recent
history doing the same thing
and anticipation of the
future, all on top of what
actually happens in this trial.
So those are not deal killers.
But they're things
to be aware of.
So those are reasons
why you might
want to go with this
condition or this condition.
Why wouldn't you always do this?
Alternate the order--
not alternate.
Randomize the order of
conditions over time
and bunch them in together.
Why is that not
always a great idea?
People do that sometimes.
It's not a terrible idea.
But there are things
to keep in mind here.
What's the challenge with that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: One possible challenge
is that the bold response
has a 10-second window.
So it's scraggly.
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
So the bold responses here
are going to be massively
on top of each other.
That's why people
sometimes do this.
It's like, OK, we'll
have a random order.
And we'll put a big
chunk of time in between.
But if you have to stick 10
seconds in between trials,
your subject is
going to fall asleep.
And you're spending all
that expensive scan time
not collecting enough trials.
So none of these
is right or wrong.
They're right or wrong
in different conditions.
So as Eke-- am I
saying it right?
As Eke mentioned,
the challenge here--
let me just give you my
crude depiction of this.
So let's suppose this is
time, a series of trials
with a house, a dot,
a face, a dot, a dot--
I don't know where that
dot went-- a face, a house,
et cetera.
And each of those trials
is one second long.
Well, let's imagine the response
in the fusiform face area
to that first house.
You get some kind of
middling low response
that's going to take
many seconds to peak.
Let's look at the
response to this face.
Well, it's going to be higher.
And it's going to
peak out there.
And so then you can
look at the response
of each of these things.
And so you get this whole
series of bold responses
from each of those
different trials.
But now, here's the problem.
What we observe when we measure
the response of a little voxel,
a little three-dimensional
pixel in the brain,
is the sum of all of
that, something like this.
It'll be higher than that,
but some big blurry sum
of all that.
So now, we want to go
backwards from observing
this to seeing the difference
between that and that.
And that's a problem.
So that's not great.
But here's the crazy thing.
It's not impossible.
It's not impossible because
by weird, mysterious, to me
still kind of unfathomable
physiological mechanisms,
these things add up
approximately linearly.
It's really counterintuitive.
Who would think a big
sloppy biological system
with many different causal
steps could produce something
that is approximately linear?
But it does.
And because they
add up linearly,
if you have enough trials,
you can take this thing
and recover that and that.
We're not going to go
through the math of it.
It's just basically addition.
It's solving for
multiple equations
because you have all these
different time points.
Did everybody get
the gist of the idea
that even if you're observing
something really slowly varying
and weakly varying because
it's massively blurred,
you could, in principle,
with enough trials,
go backwards and solve
for that and that?
Everybody get that idea?
So what that means is it's
a bit of an uphill battle
to do a fast
event-related thing.
You can't just look
at the response.
You have to actually
do a lot of math.
And you may or may not have
enough trials to pull it out.
But under some circumstances
where you really
need things to be interleaved,
you can pull that off.
All right.
So that's what I just said.
Blah, blah, blah.
A few other design things
that I didn't really
talk about in detail--
one I've mentioned
glancingly, but I
want it to be more explicit
about it, this whole idea
that we've talked about
a few times of defining
a region of the brain
that we're going
to look at with a localizer
scan with functional MRI.
We talked about that with the
case of characterizing face
areas.
Go run a face
versus object scan.
Find the face area
in that subject.
And then do new
experiments and testing.
Or when you guys proposed
your snake experiments,
you said, first, localize a
candidate snake-specific region
with snakes versus non-snakes.
And then do repeated
tests in that region
that you found in each subject.
Why do we have to do all
that within each subject?
You don't technically have to.
Lots of people don't.
But the reason I
think it's important
and the reason we
do it in my lab
and all of my
intellectual descendants
do that and lots of
other people do, too,
the reason we do that is
that region is not in exactly
the same place in each subject.
So I have a dopey analogy.
Brains are physically different
from one person to the next.
If we scan you guys
just anatomically
and look at the
structure of your brains,
your brains are as
different from each other
as your faces are.
That is, you all have
the same basic structure,
the same major lobes and
sulci, just as you all
have eyes and nose and mouth.
But they're in slightly
different positions.
And that's just the anatomy.
The function on top of
that is even more variable.
So it's like trying
to align faces.
So if you have a bunch
of photographs of faces
and you try to align
them on top of each other
and superimpose
them, even if you
have a few degrees of stretch,
you can't do it perfectly.
You'll get some kind
of mess like this.
Just they're different.
So they don't
perfectly superimpose.
Well, it's the same
deal with brains.
You try to align them perfectly
from one person to the next,
but they're
physically different.
They do not perfectly
superimpose.
So now, imagine that-- this
is a totally crazy analogy.
But it's the best I
could come up with.
Suppose you're a dermatologist.
And you're interested
in skin cancers
that arise in the upper lip.
Well, it could happen.
There's more sunlight hitting
the upper lip, whatever.
So now, you could take a whole--
and you're studying photographs
to try to see how many people
have it or something like that.
So you could take a whole
bunch of photographs.
And you could just say, OK,
I'm going to look right there.
It's usually going
to be the upper lip.
But it's not always going
And so you're really throwing
away a lot of information
by choosing the wrong location.
For this person down
here, you missed it.
You're looking at
the wrong thing.
So in the same way, if you
want to study that region,
you've got to find it on
each individual photograph.
And similarly, if you
want to study the fusiform
face area or the snake area--
which doesn't exist,
but whatever--
you've got to go find that thing
in that person individually.
Otherwise, you're really
blurring your data
just as those data
are blurred there.
Make sense?
All right.
Good.
Different topic
about design-- these
are just kind of
different topics.
I couldn't find a good segue.
So far, we have been talking
about the most rudimentary
simple possible
experimental design.
That means two conditions--
faces and objects,
snakes and non-snakes,
moving or stationary,
whatever-- two conditions
where you contrast and
you look in the brain.
Is there a higher
response to A than B?
Nothing wrong with that--
you can get pretty
far with this.
But first of all,
of course, we can
have more than two conditions.
So you can have one factor--
in this case,
stimulus category--
with many different conditions--
faces, bodies, objects,
scenes, whatever.
So that's not rocket science.
We've just added a few more
conditions of the same factor.
Here, factor is the
dimension you're varying.
In this case, it's
stimulus type.
But we could get fancy.
And we could have
four conditions
that are two factors varied
orthogonally, like this.
This is sometimes
called a 2 by 2 design.
We're going to vary one thing
on this axis and another thing
on this axis.
Why would we want to do that?
Well, let's look at an example.
Now, let's suppose
that you were going
to compare faces to objects--
in this case, chairs.
But beyond just
those two conditions
of comparing the response in the
brain when people are looking
at faces versus objects,
we could now ask,
does a response in the
brain to faces and objects
depend on whether
you're paying attention
to the faces and objects?
What if you're paying
attention to something else?
What if we have little
colored letters right
in the middle of the display
and they're changing rapidly
over time and your
task is to monitor
for a repetition of a
letter, a one-back task?
And it's going really fast.
So it's very demanding.
You're just looking
at those letters.
They're flashing up.
Oh, two B's.
You hit a button.
It's very demanding.
The information
hitting your retina
is still coming
in from the face,
because the little
letter is tiny.
It's not hiding
much of the face.
What do you think?
If you're doing the
letter task, do you
think you'll still get a
response in the fusiform face
area when the face comes up?
And will it be higher than
when the chairs come up?
Any intuitions?
Yes?
Talk to me about that.
AUDIENCE: It should
be because I think
what people are doing
is the signal winds
and hits the retina.
There'll be one in
the process of it.
NANCY KANWISHER:
It's still coming in.
Yeah.
Will it be just as high?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: No, I don't
think it'd be as high.
But I think there'd be
some response that's
higher than that for chairs.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Does everybody see
how this is kind of an
interesting question?
The machinery is the same.
All the feed-forward
stuff is the same.
You can't-- when I tell you
just now you're doing the letter
task, now you're
doing the face task,
when you switch to
the letter task,
the wiring in your
brain doesn't change.
All the same wiring is there.
The stimulus is still
hitting your retina.
It's still going up the system.
So it becomes interesting to
ask how could it be different.
Would it be different?
All right.
I just wanted you all
in the grip of this
is a question that we might ask.
So how could we
ask this question?
Well, we can do--
as I just said,
we can have subjects in one case
do their standard object task.
Look for consecutive repetitions
of a face or of a chair.
We can have all different
kinds of chairs.
But every once in a while,
two in a row are the same.
Or we could have this other
task where they're monitoring
for letter repetitions.
So does everybody get
this 2 by 2 design?
On one factor, we're
varying the stimulus.
Is it faces or objects?
Faces or objects, those
are the two conditions.
That's just terminology.
And on the other factor,
we're varying task.
Are you doing the face-object
task or the letter task?
Yeah.
Ben, is it?
AUDIENCE: So what is
it that this task--
what conclusions does it allow
you to draw that the simpler
task won't?
NANCY KANWISHER: Good question.
Good question.
Anybody have an intuition here?
You mean other than just doing
that, never mind the letters?
AUDIENCE: Right.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes, exactly.
Exactly the right question.
You guys, what do you think?
Is there any reason to do this?
Does anybody care about this?
What would it tell us?
Yeah.
I forget your name.
LAUREN: Lauren.
NANCY KANWISHER: Lauren.
Yeah.
LAUREN: The effect of
attention on perception.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
So if we want to know
not just is there
some bit that responds more
to faces than objects--
we've been doing that for weeks.
Enough already.
We know there is.
Now, we want to know
does it matter what
you're paying attention to.
Is that thing just
like a little machine
that's going to do its
thing no matter what?
Or do you, the perceiver,
have any control over it?
Here's another version
of that question.
You guys can all
sit there and look
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed
and look at me and smile and nod
and think about whatever
you want to think about.
And I won't know.
You could be bored
out of your mind,
thinking about what you
did last night, whatever.
And I won't know.
And that's great.
Isn't that nice, that
we human beings are not
trapped by the stimulus that's
in front of us at any moment?
Instead, we can control
our mental processes
to some degree.
And if you choose to think about
something else, you go for it.
You have good judgment.
That is fine.
It happens to me all the time.
You have that ability.
I have that ability-- not
really when I'm lecturing.
I kind of have to stay on task.
That's why it's exhausting.
But anyway, we are not trapped.
We are not completely controlled
by the sensory world impinging
on us.
And that's a good thing.
And so if you wanted to find
out about how that works
and study how well
we can control
our own mental processes, you
would do something like this.
Make sense?
All right.
So this design enables us to
ask a whole bunch of things.
One, does a response
in some region or voxel
or wherever we're looking
depend on stimulus category?
This is what we've been talking
about for a couple weeks now.
To do that, you
could just say, OK,
is there an overall
higher response
to these two conditions
than those two conditions?
You wouldn't worry about task.
You just say, overall,
is there a bit
that likes faces
more than objects?
Everybody got that?
That's one thing.
That's sort of what we've been
doing so far is just comparing
two levels of one factor.
That's called a main effect--
in this case, a main effect
of the factor stimulus type.
Or we could ask a
different question.
Does the response of a region of
the brain depend on attention?
So overall, never mind
whether it's faces or objects.
There are photographs
flashing up there.
Does it matter if you're paying
attention to those photographs
or paying attention
to something else?
So for that, we compare
the average of these two
versus the average of those two.
That would be a
main effect of task.
Make sense?
It's just terminology.
But it's important
to see that we
can ask these different
questions of a 2 by 2 design.
Everybody with me?
Anybody want to
ask me something?
This main effect isn't
very interesting.
It's kind of a weird
one, but you could do it.
So that's main effect
of attention or task.
Now, we could ask, as someone
else said a moment ago--
was that you, Lauren?
Yes-- if we want to know, does
the effect of stimulus category
depend on attention?
That's what a 2 by 2 design
is-- it's that kind of question
that a 2 by 2 design
enables you to ask.
So to ask that question,
really, what we would do
is essentially look at
this row and then that row.
And then we compare them.
So we might say how much
higher of a response
you get for faces and objects.
And we get some
number in that cell--
sorry, when you're
paying attention to them.
And how much would you get when
you're not paying attention
to them?
You're paying attention
to the letters.
And then we could
say, oh, how selective
is the face response when it's
attended versus unattended?
In other words, how do
the response to stimuli
depend on task?
It's not rocket science.
But it's important to see
how this humble little 2 by 2
enables you to ask these
very different questions.
So this question of how
the effect of one factor
depends on the level you're
at with the other factor
is called an interaction.
And it's often the most
interesting kind of question
to ask of any kind
of data, whether it's
MRI or anything else.
You could think of it as a
difference of differences
or, more directly, how
the effect of one factor
depends on the level
of the other factor.
In this case, the
terminology would
be we would be looking at
an interaction of stimulus
category by task.
Make sense?
Everybody with the
program about how
this question is different than
the two different main effect
questions?
To get some practice
with this, I'm
going to have you guys come
up here and draw some data.
So we're going to consider a--
just to get experience with
main effects and interactions,
we're going to consider a
main effect of factor X, which
is an overall effect of X, the
difference between condition
one versus condition
two within X.
And we're going to consider
interactions of factor X
and factor Y. That is
how the effect of X
depends on Y and vice versa.
So I'm going to have
you guys draw data.
I need my first volunteer.
This is not hard.
How do I put this thing up?
I forgot to check if I
have red and black pens.
Hopefully, I do.
If you don't volunteer,
I'm going to pick randomly.
And that could be worse.
It's not too awful.
Is it Carrie?
Unfortunately, I
remember your name.
So come on up here.
So you got an easy one.
This doesn't write very
well, but it will do.
This is your red pen.
That's your black pen.
So we have here the
response in red or orange
will be the attended case.
We're looking at a response
in the fusiform face
area, a possible response--
in this case, a pretty
unlikely one.
But never mind-- so
the attended one.
And there's an unattended one.
And there's a response
to objects and faces.
And what I want you
to draw is a pattern
of data in which there's no
main effect of stimulus type,
no main effect of attention,
and no interaction of stimulus
type by attention.
So you're going
to draw four dots.
You can do X's and
O's or whatever.
CARRIE: So no effect
of the stimulus--
so that means it doesn't matter
if it was a face or an object.
NANCY KANWISHER: Uh-huh.
Exactly.
CARRIE: So I guess--
NANCY KANWISHER: You
could do that for one.
Go do that for the
attended task first.
Do that in red.
Yeah.
CARRIE: So about midway.
NANCY KANWISHER: You have
to really lean on it.
Oh, it worked for me.
Sorry.
We'll have the extremely
counterintuitive thing
of this is attention.
There we go.
Here you go.
Perfect, no main effect
of stimulus type.
Good.
Now, we've got no main
effect of attention.
So take the blue pen.
CARRIE: So this is like--
NANCY KANWISHER:
And no interaction--
CARRIE: No effect of attention
relative to attention?
NANCY KANWISHER: That's right.
No main effect of attention
means no difference
for attended and unattended.
CARRIE: OK.
But stimulus type
is important now.
NANCY KANWISHER: No, no, no.
We're still-- this
is all the same.
We're drawing all
the same situation.
Yeah, exactly.
It's a little bit
of a-- there you go.
Beautiful.
Nicely done, Carrie.
So that's kind of a dopey case.
Well done.
You can sit down.
Yeah.
CARRIE: Hopefully,
I seemed right.
NANCY KANWISHER: So we're
just starting basic here.
That's what it looks like
if you have no main effects
and no interactions.
Everything's the same.
All right.
That's not going to happen if
you're in the fusiform face
area.
If you get that, there's
something wrong with your scan.
Or something went way wrong.
But we're just fleshing out
the logical possibilities.
I need the next volunteer.
Who's going to do a main
effect of stimulus type,
no main effect of attention, and
no interaction of stimulus type
by attention?
Yes.
Come on up here.
Is it-- what's your name?
AKWILE: Akwile.
NANCY KANWISHER: Sorry?
Akwile.
Yes.
Right.
Great.
So go ahead and
draw that for me.
I'm just going to clarify
that this-- what did we do?
This is unattended--
wait a minute.
Yeah, unattended here.
Here you go.
AKWILE: Oh, static.
So you start with the--
NANCY KANWISHER: There's
main effect of stimulus type.
It's probably easiest
if you start-- yeah,
start with attended.
There's a main effect
of stimulus type.
Great.
You're in the FFA.
The faces are going to be
higher than the objects.
And main effect of
stimulus type says
you're going to
get a difference.
Good.
AKWILE: Is that good?
NANCY KANWISHER: Beautiful.
Well done.
Make sense to everyone?
Thank you, Akwile.
Does that make sense, everyone?
So what would this
mean if you got this?
OK, Akwile.
You're not quite done.
So you get that.
What's that telling you?
AKWILE: It tells you that
it responds to the stimulus.
But the attention doesn't make
any difference to the energy.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
The selectivity you
get doesn't depend
on attention in this case.
Again, these are all--
we're just making up data.
We're just considering
the different ways
the data could come out and
what they would tell us.
Everybody got that?
Now, the plot is going
to thicken a little bit.
Now, we're going to
have a main effect
of stimulus and main
effect of attention
and no interaction of
stimulus by attention.
Let's go ahead up here.
Is it Talia?
Come on up here.
Here.
Mm-hmm.
Beautiful.
Thank you.
Everybody see how this is a
main effect of stimulus type.
Faces are higher than objects,
a main effect of attention.
Attended is higher than
unattended, but no interaction.
The effect of stimulus type
is the same at each level.
Yeah?
Ben.
BEN: Just something
that maybe was unclear
for me-- does attention
usually affect
the selectivity or
the average response?
NANCY KANWISHER: These
are great questions.
Right now, we're
just considering
the logical possibilities.
We'll talk about that later.
Yeah, it's a good--
you should be wondering.
Yeah.
So Talia, tell us.
If you found that,
what would that mean?
TALIA: So because the
difference in effect
between attended and
unattended objects and faces
is the same, that does show
that attention plays an effect
and the stimulus
plays an effect.
But there's no
interaction between them,
because the difference
is the same.
NANCY KANWISHER: It's like there
are these two different things.
There's face selectivity.
And then there's
just a big overall
if you're looking at stuff,
you get higher responses
than if you're looking
at the letters.
Yeah, exactly.
All right.
One more-- I need a volunteer.
David.
That's not a
volunteer, I realize.
It's different than a volunteer.
So draw me a case where you
have a main effect of stimulus,
a main effect of attention,
and an interaction of stimulus
by attention.
DAVID: This one.
And then it goes like this.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Beautiful.
So here, we have--
oh, wait.
Actually, hang on.
Hang on.
Wait a second.
You got a main
effect of stimulus.
Actually, you don't have a
main effect of stimulus here.
DAVID: Did I get rid of that?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
you got rid of that.
DAVID: I come back.
NANCY KANWISHER: Ah.
Now, you have a main
effect of attention.
DAVID: Wait.
NANCY KANWISHER: Wait.
Oh, maybe I said it wrong.
You didn't have--
OK.
Wait a second.
DAVID: Oh, yeah.
You're right.
AUDIENCE: No, he
has a main effect.
NANCY KANWISHER: I think
I screwed you up here.
We want a main
effect of stimulus.
Yeah.
DAVID: Yeah.
And then let's just we move
it a little bit like that.
And we get--
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
So don't go away.
Does everybody see how this
is a main effect of stimulus?
Those guys are higher
than those guys.
A main effect of
attention-- the green guys
are higher than the blue
guys, but an interaction
like that difference is
bigger than that difference.
Now, don't go away, David.
If you got that, what
would you conclude
about the fusiform face
area if you got those data?
DAVID: Well, the FFA, if it
was like this, it depends--
not only does it
depend on attention.
But it kind of depends
on attention more than--
maybe the object attention
doesn't depend on attention
so much.
NANCY KANWISHER: That's right.
That's what your data show
is that the response to faces
is more strongly affected by
attention than the response
to objects.
But another way of
saying the same thing
is to say that the
selectivity is greater
when you're attending than
when you're not attending.
Make sense?
Or the differential
response is greater.
Great.
Thank you.
Everybody got these basic ideas?
They're pretty rudimentary.
I don't want to insult
your intelligence.
But I really found that people
often don't get main effects
and interactions.
And often, really, the crux
of an interesting design
is an interaction.
And keeping it straight
from the main effects
sometimes takes a little doing.
So let's consider what is the
key sign of an interaction.
Oh, well, we already have
a case where, often, people
draw an interaction
where the lines cross.
But they don't need to cross.
David just showed you
a nice interaction
where the lines don't cross.
All right.
Moving on-- that
was all leftovers.
That's bad planning.
Oh, sorry.
What?
Oh, yes, put the thing up.
Good point-- or down.
Thank you, Chris.
Let's talk about
category-selective regions
of the visual cortex.
We have been talking
about these all along.
But it's time to get a
little more critical.
So first, I've been
talking about how
there's a patch in
there that responds
pretty selectively to faces.
There's a patch out there on the
lateral surface that responds
pretty selectively to bodies.
And we haven't
mentioned it much.
But next week, you'll
hear more than you
want to hear about a patch
smack in the middle there
that responds selectively
to images of scenes.
So you just look at that.
And it's really
damn near impossible
not to wonder what else
is lurking in there.
What else is in there?
And of course, we wondered
that many years ago,
me and Paul Downing who
did the body area paper.
He was my postdoc at the time.
And we said, well,
let's just scan people
looking at 20 different
categories of objects.
And we put in all kinds
of silly stuff in there.
I'm phobic about snakes,
so I wanted snakes.
He's phobic about spiders.
We compromised in our
creepies condition--
threw them both in there.
It was kind of sloppy.
But we had food and plants,
because we figured those
are biologically important.
We had weapons because those
are-- and tools because those
are important in other ways.
We had flowers because Steve
Pinker has this line in one
of his books saying
that "a flower is
a veritable microfiche
of biologically
relevant information."
And he hypothesized based
on that that people might
have special-purpose neural
machinery for flowers.
It sounded like a crock to me,
but it's an empirical question.
So we threw flowers in
there for Steve Pinker.
And so then we scanned people
looking at all of these things.
And we replicated
in every subject
the existence of selective
regions for places, faces,
and bodies.
And we didn't find
anything else.
None of these other
categories produced
clear whopping selectivities in
systematic regions of the kind
that you see in every subject
for faces, places, and bodies.
Now, I hasten to
say that there are
lots of ways with any method
to not see something that's
actually there.
You might not have enough
statistical power to see it.
It might be that there's a whole
bunch of neurons that do that,
but they're scattered
all over the brain.
And so they're
spatially interleaved
with neurons that do other
things, in which case
MRI will never see it.
There are big black
holes in MRI images
where there are artifacts.
And you can't see anything.
And if the soul
was right there, we
wouldn't have discovered it
yet because we can't see it
in our MRI images,
not that I know what
the contrast is for the soul.
You could work on that.
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
I'm just curious.
Did you try it on text?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes.
And we will get to that later.
And there is absolutely a
specialized region for text.
And we'll talk about
that in a few weeks.
Yeah.
We didn't in this experiment,
but we and lots of others
have in other cases.
So don't take this
too seriously.
My main point is
just that you don't
find a little patch of brain
for any damn thing you test.
Mostly, you don't find it.
There is some disagreement
in the field about the case
of tools and hands.
There are many reports that if
you look at pictures of tools
or look at pictures
of hands, you
can get a nice little
selective blob.
I have looked at both
of those many times.
I don't see it.
I don't know what
everyone else is on about.
I'm confused about that.
I just leave that as in play.
I don't know.
But with that exception, there's
good agreement that faces,
places, and bodies,
everyone replicates.
And most of these others,
no one replicates.
And so in particular, nobody
reports selective patches
of brain that respond
selectively to cars, chairs,
food, or lots of other things.
We have tested
snakes, by the way,
and not found anything,
at least in the cortex.
So what does that mean?
That implies, kinda sorta,
that some categories are
special in the brain, at
least at this crude grain
that we can see
with functional MRI.
And that seems pretty
interesting and important.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I had a
question about places.
Did you distinguish between
human-made places and naturals?
NANCY KANWISHER:
We'll get into all
of that in excruciating
detail next week.
Yeah.
It doesn't really make
much of a difference.
It likes all of those things.
Yeah.
So I've been going around
for 20 years saying, see,
these categories are
really special in the brain
and the mind.
And that's what we're
getting from this.
And that's deep and fundamental.
It's telling us something about
who we are as human beings
or whatever.
Sometimes, I go off the
deep end with huge claims.
But not everybody buys this.
And so what I want to
do is allude briefly
to the general kinds of ways
you could argue against this
and then talk in some
detail about one main one.
So ongoing controversies--
this view here
is highly caricaturized.
And this is actually not right.
The brain doesn't have
completely discrete
little regions.
It's a mucky biological system.
If you actually
look at the part,
the face-selective regions,
they have ratty edges
and little kind of archipelagos
of sub-blobs and stuff.
It's kind of a bit of a mess.
There's a general cluster in
that vicinity in most subjects,
but it isn't always a discrete
blob unless you blur your data.
You take any data
and blur it enough,
it looks nice and clean.
But if you want to know the
actual native form in the brain
unblurred, it's kind of mucky.
So one could react to
that in different ways.
My reaction to that is
like, what do you expect?
It's a biological system.
Does it really need
to be perfectly
oval-shaped with a
perfectly sharp edge?
I don't really care if it's
interleaved with other stuff
around the edges.
But people react different ways.
And one kind of important
alternative view
is, look, how do we know
that these are really
things in the brain?
I'm talking about them
as things, pieces,
parts of brain and mind.
And maybe they're
just kind of peaks
in a broader landscape of
responses across the cortex
that are fluctuating.
And empirically, that's true.
There isn't just one butte
and then nothing else
in the cortex around it.
There's some kind of profile.
So it's a bit of a
judgment call how excited
you want to be about a big peak
in a fluctuating background.
And so there's much
discussion about that.
Is it really just a peak in a
broader spatial organization?
And if so, what is that broader
spatial organization all about?
It just pushes
that question back.
It says, we're wrong to
think about discrete things.
But that still
leaves many mysteries
about what that
continuous gradient is.
So that's kind of one
line of response, which I
think is completely legitimate.
Any sort of version
of that kind of blurs
into this next view, which
we've talked about a little bit.
And that is to what
extent can these things,
if I'm calling them things,
be accounted for just
by their perceptual features.
So we've grappled with that
in a number of ways so far.
One of the first things we
asked about the face area
is, is it just responding
to curvy stuff or round
things or whatever?
And so there are
many lines of work
where me and many other people
have asked that question.
And for the most
part, the answer
seems to be there are some
featural selectivities
in these regions, but
probably not enough to account
for their category selectivity.
But that one, too,
is still in play.
And there's this
dude in England who
publishes several
papers a year saying,
no, this thing isn't
category-selective.
It's just that.
I'm going to try to
assign one of his papers
to you because I want you to
expose you to alternate views.
But I haven't yet taught
you the key methods
you need for that paper.
Anyway, so there's room for
debate in that question,
as well.
Then there's just a continuum
of OK, exactly how selective
are these regions.
I'm excited if a
face area responds
like this to faces and
like that to objects.
But hey, it responds
Is that selective enough?
So there's a lot of debate
about what that means.
So there's a lot of
room to push back
on the simpleminded story I've
been serving up to you guys.
But what I want
to do next is talk
about what I take to be the most
smart and serious challenge,
which is somewhat different
from all of these.
And this comes from
a guy up at Dartmouth
named Jim Haxby, who
published the paper that
was assigned for today.
And I intended for you to
struggle with it a little bit
and try to understand it.
But if you didn't
understand it fully,
I'm going to talk about it here.
And hopefully, that'll
make it more intelligible.
So here's the big idea
that Haxby-- there
are many ideas in that paper.
But the part of it that's
most relevant to us for now
is the following.
Even if the fusiform
face area responds weakly
to chairs and cars, in contrast
with strong response to faces,
that doesn't mean that it
doesn't hold information
about chairs and cars.
So all along, I've been just
talking about one dimension.
Does it respond like
this or like that?
And that's gotten us pretty far.
But the essence
of Haxby's idea is
that we should
care not just about
the overall mean response.
We should ask if there's
information present
in the pattern of
response across voxels.
And his point is that even if
there's a low mean response,
you could still have
information in the pattern
across voxels, even if it
averages to some low number.
And that pattern of
information could
enable you to distinguish
different categories.
So let's get very particular.
So how exactly would you tell?
So here's what Haxby
did, essentially.
Or here's the subset
of the assigned paper
that's relevant to
the current question.
If we want to know, does
the fusiform face area hold
information about
cars and chairs,
thereby arguing against
its selectivity for faces--
we should care about
information in the brain,
not just magnitude of response.
If the brain is an
information processing system,
we care what information
the parts contain,
not just how much the
neurons are firing.
All right.
So if we want to know this,
here's what you can do.
Here's a version
of what Haxby did.
You scan subjects while they're
looking at chairs and cars.
You've localized the
fusiform face area
so you know where it is.
So now, you get the response.
This is highly schematic.
This is an idealized version
of the cortical surface.
Remember, the
cortex is a surface.
So we can
mathematically unfold it
and look at the
magnitude of response
of each voxel in the FFA.
FFA isn't square, but
we're idealizing it here.
Everybody get how that could
be a pattern of response
across voxels in the FFA when
the subject looks at chairs?
And maybe you have
some other pattern when
the subject is looking at cars.
Now, certainly, the
pattern when they're
looking at faces, all of these
bars would be much higher.
But our point is that
even if these are low,
they're different across voxels.
So that's step one.
So then what Haxby says
is you do the same thing
in the same subject.
You do it again, hopefully
in the same scanning session.
And you get another
pattern, like this and this.
Now, here's the key question.
If those patterns are
systematic for chairs
and systematically
different for cars,
then there is information
in that region
about the difference
between chairs and cars.
And chairs and
cars aren't faces.
So that's an important
challenge to my story about how
that region only does faces.
So how do you measure that?
Well, there's lots of ways.
Haxby's is the lowest
tech and most intuitive.
He just says, let's look at
the similarity of this pattern
to that pattern, repeated
measures on cars--
I'm sorry-- chairs, same
subject-- chairs on the even
runs and chairs on the odd runs.
By the way, why do you split
your data like this rather than
like this?
He does eight runs.
We could take the first half of
the runs, put those data here,
and the second half and
put them over there.
Or we could take
the data like this
and take even runs and odd runs.
Why is even and odd better
than first half, second half?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I guess
it doesn't allow
the subjects to get used
to one particular thing
one after the other.
NANCY KANWISHER: Well,
they're doing the same thing.
It's all the same data.
It's just how you analyze it.
Yes.
What's your name?
BAYLA: Bayla.
NANCY KANWISHER: Bayla.
Yeah.
BAYLA: I'm not sure.
I think it's probably easier
to compare between one
face and the other, I guess.
NANCY KANWISHER: You can
actually do it either way.
It's like you scan
these eight runs.
Here they are.
You can do that.
I don't know if you
can see what I'm
doing here with my whole crew.
Or you can do this.
Why is this better than this?
Yeah.
Isabel.
ISABEL: It could be a
subject was really tired.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Maybe they fell asleep
halfway through the scan.
Then if you do like
this, the odd and even
are going to be better compared
to each other than first half,
second half.
Make sense?
It's another version of why
you do things within subjects.
It's the same kind of argument.
Yeah.
So he splits into even and odd.
And so you ask, how similar
are they within a category,
within chairs and within cars?
You get two different
correlation values.
Just how similar
are those patterns?
You get an r value.
And we compare that
with how similar
the patterns are between chairs,
even, to cars, odd, and cars,
even, to chairs, odd.
And so the key
question you ask--
if there's information about
chairs and cars in this pattern
of responses, then
the correlations
will be higher within-category
than between-category.
In other words,
two different times
you scan looking at
chairs, those patterns
are more similar than
chairs are to cars.
Make sense?
It's pretty basic.
But it's one of these things
that's simple and yet subtle
at the same time.
Does everybody get this?
So you just do these
repeated measures.
And you look at these
patterns of correlations.
And if the patterns are
more similar or more
correlated within a category
than between categories,
then you have information
in that pattern
that enables you to
distinguish those categories.
Yeah?
So that's what Haxby did.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if this
information doubles,
so would it be difficult
to look at correlation?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Nothing, really.
Well, wait a second.
Oh, that's the same.
That's essentially like this.
It's just that since
we're going from even
to odd in the within
case, we're going
to go even to odd
in the between case.
You could have done it
this way, but then--
yeah.
So that's the method.
What does Haxby find?
Well, you guys could
all look at the paper
some more so you
get a sense of it,
because it's actually
really nicely written,
even though it's dense.
Those science papers
are very dense.
But basically,
here's what happened.
So in that paper,
he says, yes, he
can distinguish between
cars and chairs in the FFA.
And therefore, to
quote from his paper,
"regions such as the 'FFA'"--
notice the scare quotes he's
putting there to diss me.
I hear you.
I hear you, Jim.
"Regions such as
the 'FFA' are not
dedicated to representing
only human faces.
Rather, they're part of a
more extended representation
for all objects."
Them's fighting words.
Everybody see how this
is a serious challenge
with a very elegant method?
So when I first read that
paper, I was like, huh.
All right.
I'm paying attention.
But he didn't do
everything right.
I didn't like the way
he defined the FFA.
I found a million
reasons to diss it.
And I ran my own version.
And in my paper
that we published,
we could not discriminate those.
So we said, ha.
You can.
We can't.
You did it wrong.
We did it right.
Then a few years later,
Jim publishes a paper
with a collaborator in which
they re-analyzed their old data
and said, actually, you
really can't discriminate it
very well.
It was significantly above
chance, but really lousy.
And so they
concluded, "Preferred
regions for faces and
houses"-- that is, regions
that respond preferentially
to faces or houses--
"are not well-suited to
object classifications
that do not involve faces
and houses, respectively."
But I didn't get to
gloat because right
about the same time, we
were redoing our experiments
at higher resolution.
And actually, we
could distinguish
two different non-faces
in the fusiform face area.
So that was the little
drama that unfolded.
And so the current
status is yes,
you really can discriminate two
different non-face categories
within the fusiform face
area, even if you do it right.
Even if I do it right and
I don't want that result
and I do it right, I
can get that result.
So that's true empirically.
The ability to
discriminate is feeble.
It's not very strong, but
it's significantly greater
than chance.
So does that mean I'm toast
and I wasted the last few weeks
telling you guys a bunch of
BS that has been disproven
and that I should not
have been telling you?
Yeah.
David.
DAVID: Isn't it
kind of like saying
that you could use a
vending machine like a clock
and then ask the question,
then what is this thing for?
Well, it's obviously
the office clock.
NANCY KANWISHER:
That's a great analogy.
I love that.
Absolutely.
So now, to me, the central
question-- and here's
another example that I
think is exactly like that,
but even more on point.
And that is that there
are deep nets that people
have trained on faces.
VGG Face, it's really
good at face recognition.
It has only ever seen faces.
It has only been
trained on faces.
That is all it's about.
And if you feed it
chairs or-- what
do I have-- chairs and
cars, it can discriminate
between chairs and cars.
So even if you have this
perfect representation
that's only been trained on
faces, that has only evolved--
if it evolved.
We'll get to that later--
to deal with faces,
it can still give you
a somewhat different
response to chairs and cars.
And that doesn't mean that
that's what it's doing.
So I think this is a
really important challenge.
But I think
centrally, crucially,
what we really need to
be thinking about-- maybe
Akwile has a contribution.
Yeah.
AKWILE: So if it's only
been trained on faces
and you feed it a chair,
what's the outcome?
What's it say?
NANCY KANWISHER: So it's just
a bunch of feed-forward layers
that are connected
with boatloads
of units at each
thing and connected
in the systematic pattern.
And once you train it up,
you can feed it any stimulus.
And you can collect a
response out the top.
So even though it was
designed for and only
been trained on faces, you
can feed it in non-faces
and get the response
out the top and see.
That is not the category,
not the top layer
where it says that's
Joe or that's Bob.
But just before
that layer, there's
a whole bunch of units that have
some representation distributed
across units.
You can take that and try
to read it out and ask
if there's information there.
I'm not giving you all the
details of how you do that.
But hopefully, you can
get at least the gist.
And later in the
semester, Katharina Dobs
is going to tell
you more about how
you do all this kind of stuff.
I spent a lot of time in
the last few weeks talking
about a key difference between
two different kinds of methods,
one set of methods that
allows this kind of inference
and another set of methods that
allows that kind of inference.
I'm trying to give
you guys a clue here.
Actually, what I'm going to do
is let you percolate on this.
I don't think this is obvious.
I worried about this for years.
I think there are
many answers to it.
It's not cut and dried.
I will say I have already
presented to you at least
two different lines
of work that provide
an important
counterargument to this.
One of the people who gave me
crappy teaching evaluations
last year said, she told
us about counterarguments
and then made us tell her
how they could in fact,
after all, be consistent
with her data.
I thought that was weird.
I was just trying to teach
people to think about data.
But anyway, I won't make
you do that because somebody
didn't like that before.
But you can think about it.
And we'll talk later.
And it's actually
good to think about.
And we will come back to it.
But I want to get
on with the rest.
I mention all this because
it is an important challenge.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering
if objects are not
processed in FFA, they must
be processed somewhere else.
NANCY KANWISHER: Totally.
AUDIENCE: Somewhere else.
I had a whole piece of
this lecture on that.
And then I thought,
for once, I'm
not going to go over my time.
So I'm not going
to talk about that.
But remember, there's all
those other bits of cortex.
I've just identified
a few particular ones.
There's lots of
cortex in between.
And the simple
statement is there's
a lot of nearby
cortex near the FFA
and the PPA that seems
to respond generically
to object shape.
And the first-pass
guess is that there's
a general-purpose
visual machine in there,
in addition to some
more specialized ones.
But I'm going to not
say more at the moment.
And I'll just say, actually,
you may read it in papers.
It's sometimes called LO or LOC.
That's kind of a
shape-selective region which
is arguably the kind of generic,
let's process everything else
system.
Only if it's a
clarification question.
Ask it.
AUDIENCE: No.
I was just wondering which
came first, this work
or the transcranial stuff.
NANCY KANWISHER: Sorry.
This work or--
AUDIENCE: Or the transcranial.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Ah, good question.
The transcranial
stuff has actually
been going on for a long time.
But the relevant kind
that I talked to you about
is more recent.
And you're right.
It is one of the
very strong answers
to this kind of critique.
There's several.
Actually, I've told you about
three, so far, answers to this.
But think about it.
So what we're going to do
now is talk about not just
this particular
use of this method
to ask a serious question about
the selectivity of regions
in the ventral visual pathway.
Now, what I'm going to do
is argue that, actually--
I think I just
said all of this--
what Haxby has given
us is also a method
to ask what information is
present in this little patch
of the brain.
And that's an awesome thing.
So let's go on and
talk about that.
Let's talk about neural
decoding with functional MRI.
So that was an
instance of it, but I'm
going to cash it out in
another way more generally.
So let's take the
case where there's
a person with a
patch of their brain
and a pattern of
response across voxels
in that patch of
their brain when
they look at some stimulus.
Let's suppose you're given this.
And you want to know what
was that person looking at
to produce that pattern.
What was the stimulus
out in the world
that produced that pattern?
Can you do that?
So more generally, can you read
the mind with functional MRI?
Or maybe a little more
honestly, can you at least
tell what the person saw
from their pattern of brain
response?
Everybody get the question here?
How can we try this?
Well, they're all variations
of that Haxby method
that I just told you about.
But let's walk through this.
So the first thing you need
is you have this pattern.
And you're trying
to figure out what
stimulus produced that pattern
in that part of this person's
brain.
Well, you need a decoder.
You need to know what
those voxels respond
like when they look
at different things,
where you know the answer.
So what you do is
you scan the subject
on a bunch of different
conditions to get your decoder.
And then you can take
your unknown data
and compare it to
those decoder data.
So in particular, you have
to train your decoder.
So you scan the person
looking at, say, shoes,
and you get pattern.
You scan them looking at
cats, and you get a pattern.
Maybe you scan them looking at
five, 10, 100 other things--
probably not 100.
You don't have
enough scan time--
but some number of things.
And so now, you know.
You know this is how
those voxels respond
when the person looks at shoes.
And this is how those voxels
respond when they look at cats.
Now, you test your decoder
with your mystery pattern.
Now, you have your
mystery unknown pattern.
And you want to know,
was that shoes or cats?
Well, you can just look.
What is it most similar to?
All the methods are
versions of that.
They're just fancy
mathematical versions of that.
So what do you
think that pattern--
what produced that pattern?
AUDIENCE: Shoes.
NANCY KANWISHER: Shoes.
It's more similar
to the shoe pattern.
Exactly.
You guys just did
neural decoding.
So that's exactly
how you do this.
There are all kinds of ways of
doing this, from just saying,
is this more correlated
with that than that?
That's Haxby's version.
Or you can put a whole big
fancy machine learning rigmarole
in there to do pattern
classification,
because that is, after all,
what machine learning is
so awesome at is
pattern classification.
And this is just a
straightforward pattern
classification task.
Train on these.
Test on that.
Is that sort of intuitive,
what we're doing here?
So that's the agenda.
That's the logic
of how we do this.
And so does that work?
Well, a little bit.
But you don't have to worry,
at least at the moment,
because there are
a million ways.
About 10 years ago, I
was getting called up
by legal types all
the time because,
are people going to detect
lies with functional MRI?
And I thought this
was a total crock.
And I was going around giving
talks on all the reasons
why nobody has to worry that
they're going to be compelled
to testify by being
shoved in a scanner
and have their brains read.
It's not a totally stupid
thing to worry about.
But lest anybody--
I don't think this will happen.
But lest anybody try to read
your mind against your will
while you're in an MRI
scanner, you can totally
foil it in any number of ways.
One, move your head.
Two, if they've got your head
bolted down, move your tongue.
You totally mess up your whole
signal if you move your tongue.
Three, do mental arithmetic.
You can totally
shut down whatever
they're trying to do if you
think about something else.
Anyway, so we don't
need to worry about it.
It's not good for insidious
kind of legal efforts.
But it is pretty good
for science sometimes.
So there are lots of versions of
neural decoding with functional
MRI.
So we've been talking
so far about decoding
functional MRI patterns
of response across voxels.
That's called MVPA, Multiple
Voxel Pattern Analysis.
You don't need to memorize that.
But when you see
MVPA in a paper,
this is what it's talking about.
But you can also do it with lots
of other kinds of neural data.
Oh, sorry.
Within MVPA, you can ask it of
a particular ROI in the brain,
Region Of Interest,
like V1 or the face area
or the body area
or something else.
But you can also apply it to
the whole damn pile of data
from the whole
brain and say, can I
tell what this person
is thinking by looking
at their whole brain?
Beyond functional
MRI, you can apply it
to lots of other kinds of data.
So you can do monkey
neurophysiology,
as we discussed
briefly last time,
where you have actual firing
rates from individual neurons.
And you can look at the
response of each stimulus class
to each neuron in a
region of the brain.
And you can do the same deal,
running a pattern classifier
or a simple correlation method
on the pattern of response
across neurons,
rather than voxels.
Everybody see how that's sort
of the same deal, just better?
Or you can do
magnetoencephalography,
as we've talked about.
Stick your head in the
big expensive hairdryer.
Collect magnetic
signals from all
around the head, 300 channels.
And now, those magnetic
signals are changing over time.
So the cool thing about
neural decoding with MEG
is you can say, OK, let's take
the data from just exactly 80
milliseconds after the
stimulus flashed on.
And let's ask, what
can you decode then?
What can you decode at 100
milliseconds, 120 milliseconds?
You can see the
growth of information
over time as neural
information processing proceeds
by running the decoder
separately at each time point.
I'm going to try to squeeze
into a future lecture
more talk about that,
because I think it's cool.
And we're doing a lot of
it in my lab right now.
Does everybody get the
gist of this, at least?
So that gives you
the time course
of information extraction.
Similarly, there are lots of
different decoding methods.
You can use, as I
mentioned, the kind
of simple, low-tech
Haxby-style correlations.
Or you can use something
called linear support vector
machines or various other
kinds of fancy machine
learning math to do
those classifiers.
Let's take-- do I
have time to do this?
I'm going to skip this.
Yeah, we're going to skip that.
It's cool, but we're
going to cut to the--
oh, I don't know.
No, we'll do it all.
We've got time.
All right.
So now that I've
wasted all that time
deciding whether
we had time, we're
going to compare how well
this works when you do it
on MRI versus how well
it works when you do it
on neurons in monkey brains.
So there was a beautiful
paper a few years ago
that looked at this.
So the question is here are
these face patches in monkeys
that I told you about and that
David Leopold will be talking
about at 4 o'clock today.
And so the question is
this particular one, AM,
one of the nice face
patches up there,
these guys wanted to know what
information is represented
up there in face patch AM.
Is there information about
different individual face
identities?
Can you use it to decode
which face the monkey saw?
And so they did this
experiment two ways.
One, they did monkey
neurophysiology.
They recorded from 167
different individual neurons
in that region.
And for each neuron, they
measured its response
to five different faces.
In another condition, they
popped the very same monkeys
in the scanner.
And they scanned them
with functional MRI.
And they did the
same experiment.
And they measured the
magnitude of response
of each of 100 voxels in
that same patch of brain
in that same monkey.
And they got the MRI response
to each of those 100 voxels
and for each voxel to
each of those five faces.
Everybody get that this is
asking the same question?
How well can you
decode face identity
from individual neurons
or from functional MRI
in the same animal?
And the answer is
damn depressing.
The answer is you can
decode identity really well
from neurophysiology.
And you can't do it worth a
damn with functional MRI--
big bummer.
Yeah.
So that's a drag.
It's just what it is.
Presumably, remember, each MRI
voxel has hundreds of thousands
of neurons in it.
So the real miracle is that
we ever see anything at all.
And when we can't see the
neural code with the resolution
that we need to to tell whether
it's got information about face
identity, that's
just because we're
averaging over so many neurons.
That was my lament at the
end of the lecture on Monday,
that there are so many
limitations in human methods.
And here's one of the key ones.
What are the implications?
It sucks.
Anyway, I want to get
one more idea out.
And that is-- yeah.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is that
limited to fMRI?
Or does it also
translate to EEGs?
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh,
EEG's much worse.
AUDIENCE: Worse.
NANCY KANWISHER: Much worse.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
The only thing that
might be better
someday is
intracranial recording.
But even there, you usually
don't get enough electrodes.
So you need these
very rare cases
where you have
very-high-density grids
of intracranial electrodes
that some surgeon has decided
by chance to put on
a part of the brain
where you happen
to have hypotheses
and you happen to be incredibly
lucky to test your hypothesis.
And that's very rare.
Did you have a question, Akwile?
No.
So I've been talking
about neural decoding.
And that's a way of
asking what information
is present in this
batch of neurons
or this bunch of voxels.
And that's a really
deep question
to ask for cognitive
science, because we're
interested in
information processing.
And we want to know what's
represented in each region.
It's really the
crux of the matter
in cognitive neuroscience.
But we can also use
it to ask in a richer
way about the nature of that
information in each region.
So suppose we want to know what
exactly is represented there.
We want to know not just
that it can distinguish shoes
from cats.
That's OK.
But suppose we want to know how
is it doing shoes versus cats.
Does it just know, for example,
that shoes are elongated
this way and cats are roundish?
And that's all it's using
to do its classification.
In other words, it's not
really shoes and cats.
It's this versus
that or something.
If we want to know how abstract
those representations are
or how invariant they
are to variations
in viewing conditions,
then we can
do the following cool thing.
We can train the decoder
on one set of stimuli
and test on a different
kind of stimuli.
So for example, we
can ask, or are there
representations of shoes
that are invariant to,
for example, color
and viewpoint,
chosen just because that was
the nice shoe I could find when
I was searching an hour ago?
So if we train on these and test
on that, is that going to work?
Is it going to know that this is
the same kind of thing as that?
If it does, what have we learned
about that shoe representation?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's kind
of generalizable.
NANCY KANWISHER: It's
very generalizable.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Different perspective.
NANCY KANWISHER: Totally.
It's not just this.
It's something
closer to shoeness.
And we don't know
exactly how far it is
until we test more conditions.
But exactly-- we've
shown that it's really
abstract and generalizable.
That makes it more useful.
That makes it more
cognitively interesting.
We could even go off the
deep end and say, OK,
is it the concept of a shoe?
We could scan people reading
the word "shoe" and ask,
is that going to work?
Anya's doing
experiments like that.
There are various people
looking at this kind of thing.
And so you can ask at any
level how general or invariant
is that representation.
So neural decoders
are not just gimmicks
to try to say, oh, I can
see and I can read out
what this person saw.
They're powerful
methods in science
to characterize
mental representations
and to characterize
how abstract they are.